the MVP of Super Bowl 50 and one of the
best at rushing the passer and Willie
McGinest is here to help me interview
von Miller of the two-and-oh Denver
Broncos how are you on are we going guys
I'm doing pretty good you know I know
you're on a tour for Old Spice but is
this the only show that has Willie
McGinest on at the same time only it's
the only one and honestly this is the
only one I was looking forward to
speaking with right here do you guys I
appreciate that bond even though I gotta
be honest with you I might throw the
challenge flag on that I might well I
don't know if you overheard what we were
talking about that play at the end of
Green Bay and Minnesota and how the NFL
says that that hit that that Clay
Matthews delivered on Kirk Cousins was
not only properly called you're gonna
see it on a video to be shown to the
teams about exactly how this should be
called what are your thoughts on that
Vaughn oh yes I'm calling me you know
let me tell ya I've had some of the
worst rushing the passer
I mean roughing the passer calls out and
this is this is before you know the
rules so I you know I can clearly
understand for me um what's worked for
me is I just go for the ball each as
well for the ball each and every time if
I get you know half a chance to get to
the quarterback I'm going I'm going for
the ball each and every time I said like
you know the sack for home was the
biggest play in football and I feel like
if you put a bigger emphasis on the ball
it really takes you off for the
quarterback um you know quarterback
throws the ball I'm going for the ball
I'm swatting for the ball he's throwing
it harms others hot I feel like if you
have a bigger focus on the ball in it
and really you know helps especially
from my point of view you know I'm not
back I'm not back like you doing
safeties and you know it doesn't happen
that quickly me you know I don't have
like you know so much contact like like
interior linebackers with you know fool
backs or making tackles you know I'm on
the outside I'm going after the
quarterback every single play so well
were comedians I just go for the bar
each and every time Vaughn I got a
question for you man
when and being another pass rusher we
approach different quarterbacks
differently if you're going against a
guy like Big Ben or Carson Wentz or josh
al and some of these physical guys that
are you know 64 240 it's a little more
difficult or Russell Wilson for that
matter or Cam and the super or Cam
Newton of course
you
you've got a guys that will lower their
shoulder to try to break tackles and
elude you to make plays down the field
do you feel like mentally like you got
to be a little more physical getting
these guys down because if you don't
they're gonna break the tackle and then
they're gonna make a big play they're
gonna embarrass you you're gonna hear
about it yeah yeah I totally understand
but you know like the guy like big green
if you knock the ball up you know you do
good you smile my thing you know it's
not always what happening like that you
know it's not always a easy you know
it's definitely it's definitely a tough
call it's definitely it's definitely
tough I mean we're in a tough position
right now well you know what's been
working for me is I just go for the ball
you really worry about tackling tackling
a guy sometimes I might you know
swatting miss for the ball and then I
just fall on the quarterback
you know after you great at doing it
well 24 forced fumbles in von Miller's
career two already this year year eight
for Yvonne how do you stay on top of
your game as you have what are you doing
you gotta keep on it's tough
usually gonna keep you finding stuff to
get rid of and I feel like um I've had
great examples of how to do that with
the Marcus and Elvis do it Sean Phillips
you know everybody National Football
League they don't they didn't have that
type of luxury to be around greats and
legends like that and um you know I have
and um you know what the Marcus always
did he's out he always saw something to
to better itself you know each and every
offseason should get tougher and tougher
and tougher you know it really you know
elevate your game and I something I
picked up from the markets I said that
I've been trying to do every offseason I
make it tougher and tougher and tougher
how's that been with you gonna kick me
out the league no we're not trying to
kick you out man you definitely one of
the ambassadors of the league and you do
a great job man on and off the field
I was gonna talk about you know D where
man you know we spent some time together
we had him on the network we always
talked pass rush how was that been
having him in the build I know you just
talked about it briefly but has how does
that have another guy that is one of the
great pass rushers probably be a
hall-of-famer at some point first
first-ballot I would say but how was
that having him in the locker room man
and around you'd be able to bounce ideas
and techniques and different things like
that how does it help the rest of the
pass rushers and guys like you know like
job on your team I mean for me um I'm
I'm from Dallas you know I've been a
huge fan of the markets for a long-term
benefit I'm I'm out in my game after the
markets when I was younger so when I
came into it when I came to Nashville uh
I watched you know Cowboys table watch
the markets in it got the marks on the
team so it's like getting like your
superhero or your idol on the same team
which when I play or DeMarcus for three
years and so we really were able to you
know create a special children you know
that happen it really just feels like
you have like for me if it's like I'm
getting ready for a championship fight
and I got my my sparring partner my
sparring partner it made me great it
really knows up my movies it knows
everything about me and I got him in my
corner now each and every round so it's
it's great to have a guy like that not
only for me but for guys like really
chill and you know Shaq and Shane you
know it's not too many things they have
that luxury they have a Hall of Fame
Hall of Fame defensive player to come in
and talk to you you know each week so
it's window it's been amazing
that said Von Miller he's now Dancing
with the Stars following in your
footsteps if you will you were
eliminated through week seven is that
the bar at least he needs to reach yeah
yeah I guess I guess that's the border
that he needs to reach over week seven
but football guys League they really do
well on Dancing with the Stars and you
know honestly dancing with stars it's
really dancing is probably half of it
you know you really need like some
charisma you know you gotta have some
good jokes you really got to be able to
to capture sure you know the viewers you
got to be able to capture the viewers
and capture those votes and I think
DeMarcus would be great with all it is
hmm vana
I gotta be honest we they've been around
both of you I think Vaughn is the better
dancer saying I definitely the better
dancer he got him Vaughn I know you're
being humble here but I think you got
him dancing at weddings and dancing and
walking one was totally different from
the Viennese Waltz
you know to cha-cha and on the technical
dancers was in the ballroom look he
knows the names you know Dancing with
the Stars Josh Norman almost won the
damn thing like serious about it so
before we get to your Old Spice
Case Keenum how is how has he changed
things there
Vaughn in in Denver country I mean it's
been great Marko's country - that's
really great it's been great you know
having a guy like chase he's a special
quarterback you know it's a lot of guys
who can throw the ball and make all the
make all the reads and do all of the
stuff with case really has that effect
there about him he's just a natural-born
leader
he just has this glow about him and he's
able to make all the throws it I'm one
of the sakes comfortable with case me
and our quarterback and Vaughn did the
doing looking around man your division
got a little bit better this this year
man and this kid Patrick my Holmes man
he's he's lighten things up and I know
you guys don't play him this week but uh
two weeks two weeks now as he caught
your eye I mean I know you're excited I
know it's a challenge for you and you
get up for these type of games but these
this kid is lighting it up man yeah one
of us here I mean I you know last year I
was surprised when I started patching my
Holmes was like man it was going on was
really good and we play against I mean
you see firsthand how special he is you
know he killed us last year you know he
carried that same fire over into the
cedar so yeah is 1010 touchdowns in two
weeks so here's a I don't biggest
another quarterback with it with the
same supporting cameras with Karim hun
and Tyreke he'll and Travis Kelce again
Sammy Watkins and great offensive line
they have and the great defense or they
have so they definitely have a special
team they have great coaches over there
as well our stadium may have everything
that you they have everything that you
need you know for us they're democrat
codes you will hope that they would cool
down a little bit in two weeks and you
know whenever we plan we just got a plan
- football you know we'll be all right
so it's interesting conversation we're
having here Willie your former player
now member of the paparazzi I'm the host
and we have a player and Von Miller also
a host of the old spiced foam zone
you're on the conversation you kind of
got all the bases covered here Vaughn
what's this all about with the Old Spice
foamer that you're talking about here um
I'm excited to continue the Old Spice
guy again this season may be a part of
the Old Spice foam zone it's a two day
or la footballers
it's a football game obstacle course
that's covered in Old Spice Homer no
spice former instantly lathering body
wash it's great in the shower
fans can not only watch but they can
influence the obstacle course and they
can tune in and watch the old spikes
foam zone from 5:00 p.m. to 11:00 p.m.
Eastern all of us like social media
channels in YouTube yeah YouTube twitch
and Facebook live today from 5 to 11
p.m. it does a great job with those
commercials well I mean you might want
to get into acting when you dealt with
ball man I love I love those commercials
may you do a great job and yeah my kids
dig it too Vaughn I just - before you go
my 10 year old wears glasses what would
you tell him Vaughn
oh yeah this embrace the geek I've been
wearing glasses since I was I was the
man wearing glasses wasn't in second
grade it hasn't always been cool to wear
glasses but now it is and I'm just
embrace the Greek embrace embrace
yourself be you that's right he does
that it's right back at your von Miller
thanks for joining the program all
righty thank you guys appreciate you got
in that cell von Miller the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience